bonjour bienvenue dans la gauche de détection Je suis
content que l'univers ait conspiré pour
réaligner ce qui était décentré à la minute où
la décision a été prise tout a
été adapté à un
indice d'octane incroyablement élevé s'il devait aller aller aller
[Musique]
plus drôle la saison dernière
notre émission  construit des ponts et alimente les
gens que nous saignons tous quand nous avons été coupés nous avons tous
les mêmes pensées nous ressentons tous du chagrin
et de l'amour cela a toujours été à propos de cette
humanité commune c'est un spectacle qui est pour
chacun nous sommes entourés de la meilleure
qualité d'êtres humains que nous pourrions
ça a été beau chaque fois que c'est un
vrai joint chaque lieu de tournage ils étaient
là par dizaines c'était dingue
je n'avais jamais rien vu de tel c'est à
cause du spectacle que le Brésilien aime
vraiment fou mais vraiment professionnel
alors nous devenons aussi un  une partie de cela
et les voir et écouter ces histoires
et éventuellement utiliser cette énergie tout en
filmant tous ces gens dans chaque
pays, ils sont notre groupe étendu,
cela ressemble à une grosse boule de oh mon
Dieu  lors d'un voyage ils sont fiers
de faire partie de ce tabi que nous pouvons
leur donner une fin qui vous satisfera
vous vous